would you guys prefer
a guy um
that is around your age um but he's very
ambitious and he's going places or would
you rather have someone that's 10 15
years older and he's there
someone my age and is going places okay
uh what do you mean by he's there
um let's see career-wise so one guy has
a business he's successful one guy's
starting one and it could go either way
but he's very driven and you think you
think he's going somewhere it depends on
the they're both they're both marriage
minded both same oh okay well the older
one then you'd pick the older why
um just because they have more
experience they're more wise and um
because they've had more experiences i
trust their ability to lead
um that's the main reason
yeah okay why do you say no are the
younger one
for me it's like would be more on the
same page and that we can understand
each other a little bit more even though
if you if he's more of a leader i don't
mind
because we're building something
together whereas if a guy has already
made it sometimes
they kind of may belittle you and just
undermine you a little bit and kind of
control you that's where the control
could come in
to it as well as them being older as
well it's like therefore like they know
better than you so you don't really know
nothing whereas if you're some dating
somebody who's around the same age as
you said you two are coming up together
and i'll say like a success story for
example like um
like nowadays women will go for a guy
that has money like okay that's their
preference but sometimes it's like guys
don't believe there's still women out
there that would go for a guy that's
still trying to make it as long as you
have ambition that is it if you're a guy
you don't have money and you have no
ambition then i can understand i
wouldn't really want to be with you
however if you have the ambition and the
drive and i can see that then why not by
all means we can make it together yeah
and you have something to back up that
ambition too yeah like yeah that's that
makes sense yeah i think one of the
problems that i've got with that is that
women's if you
are dating a guy who's
how can i say if you're dating below
okay
you normally make him a project
and you you kind of a woman might
want him they'll see the vision of him
being a bus driver but really is a
cleaner
so they'll work on that
when really they should be working on
themselves
and that's the problem that i have with
that like i've got my goddaughter
you know she if i say to her oh she's
now 34
34.
um
i think you'll be suited to someone
who's 37 should think oh that's too much
of a big man and i'm thinking that's
ideal for you not the guy that you've
just you know left the guy that you're
not with who was kind of relatively your
age
but you had to kind of work on him to be
the person that he is today yeah that
took a lot of work and hard you know
like disappointment
and now she's not with him so at the end
of the day for me
i actually want to meet someone at a
higher level i don't want um a come up i
can't i just don't think that it will
suit me basically i haven't got the time
or patience for that
uh what about when you were younger
would you have had the same answer
i think when i was younger i didn't know
what i know
now today and what do you know now
self-love is very important is key
and also what's key
is
where do you want to go in five years
i mean do you just want to be a
girlfriend for 10 years
how many how many girlfriends do you
think you want to be
why not you know
think more serious if you think serious
about your life you're going to get
serious outcomes
you know i mean yeah i think i started
old i started when i was 30.
so i think dating seriously
dating dating going out with men first
experience 30. now if i knew what i know
now
it would have been different
you know i would have married i wouldn't
have divorced
i would have had my kids
you know
so it would have been different when did
you get divorced oh i'm not divorced i
thought you said you would have gotten
to we wouldn't i wouldn't have got
divorced
but you wouldn't have gotten divorced
yeah so i said when did you get divorced
i didn't i haven't what i what i said
was that
i would not have been divorced because
i think i had quite traditional values
back then i wanted to be married
i wanted kids
that kind of thing
i don't i don't think that i would i
think you would you know if you had a
different mindset you would probably
marry the like and you would be divorced
by now would you what i meant was that i
would have married
and that would have been it i wouldn't
have been thinking about divorce
because sometimes when people get into
relationships they think that this is
not going to last
so you were you were scared of getting
divorced so yeah you're afraid to get
married yeah yeah but i would have been
i was so confused
can i just ask something quickly about
the the guy on a come up i think there
is a difference between a guy that says
he's on a come up and there's no proof
in the pudding versus a guy where
you know what last year you didn't even
have a job now you've got a job next
year you've got a promotion right he
might not be there yet
but i guess going back to pearl's
question what if he was on a genuine
come up like there was proof in the
pudding he wasn't just saying it
can i yeah okay
talking from experience
okay it depends i feel like it depends
how about the person that you are and
where do you want to go yourself because
personally now i'm really driven trying
to open my business i had to business
with my ex-boyfriend being together four
years blah blah let's do this together
blah blah blah perfect i wasted time
stay there we build the true business
together now i'm leaving him and you
know when you do the meeting you draw
someone out
so you do
so imagine like maybe you're thinking
now for what i want to achieve in life
because i'm there i want to open my
business you know i've got a few like
business plan there already on the table
um waiting for um
some
investors to put some money in i would
love to have someone already that is
there because my ambition and my drive
wants someone there's already no that
can like help me out for the come up you
know what i mean someone is working for
it
he's not 100 sure but it depends on the
person that you are but i feel like if
you guys are really loving you believe
in each other like you know yeah
probably both of them but personally i
would be with the older man just really
that you'd be the older man
can i just add them to what you said as
well um
so
when i say like if i want to date a guy
that's on the come up we have to align
so i know i'm dating you to marry that's
where the common ground will be that's
why communication will be key also
i'm not necessarily going to give my all
to him i always have time to have that
understanding that i need time for
myself to better myself also i'm not
going to date somebody knowing that i
still need to work on myself i need to
work on myself first before i start
dating and then when i do come when we
do come together
we can help each other in a way where
each other's helpers so as a woman i'm a
christian i understand that the man is
the leader he's the head and then i'm
the helper and i've got to submit and
not when people hear the submission
thing they think of it in the wrong way
when i say to submit is just be there
for him respect him and support what he
says i'm the neck he wouldn't be the
head without me so i'm just as important
so we also have to like communicate well
and know that okay me new dating is for
this purpose to marry so i'm not playing
about because that's where i'm at at
this stage of my life i'm not just
dating today so i'm not going to date
like five different men because i don't
have time for that i'm working on me i'm
working on my business the same with him
so as long as we have that understanding
that we are dating to marry and he's on
the comma as many of you know i was just
banned on tic tac and we are demonetized
on a daily basis on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible